i'm gonna tell you something with i'm
gonna be as honest as i possibly can but
this quarantines
and i didn't know it it saved my
marriage
and i didn't know my marriage was in
trouble agree i didn't know it and it
was heartbreaking to me
some of the things that that beth said
to me
but were real she was because you were
you were you had the blind you
you you were you had this on right yeah
yep me too
zero balance but she basically said
it's not that i you still she said i
you're still loving my life i love you
more than anything but
i'm happier when you're not here because
when you're here
you're not present and you're you upset
the apple cart you come
back with this crazy energy yeah and she
said and this isn't your fault
but i'm just more used to living alone
than i am with you and so when your wife
and mine talk or what dude and here's
another thing did they read the
same book same exact book and and and
when when i used to talk about living
with the night
and when i used to come home she would
say she would say look
you upset the flow here i have
everything down perfect
and then you come in with your energy
not that my energy was bad it's just
it's
different it's different it's a tidal
wave and then i have to rock
in the boat it takes me a day to get
everybody back
in line imagine having a four-year-old
and a nine-month-old my girl goes whoa
dude we do this this and this you come
in you can't [ __ ]
rock in the ship look at this [ __ ]
it's his first pair of kicks
by the way the first pair of kicks these
jordan ones those are the buzz
lightyears
there's some junk in that trunk that's a
big dude
look at him he kind of looks like the
gerber baby yes i mean
[ __ ] cute that ball he doesn't tell
you is eight feet big
yeah it's a big ball yes but but dude is
the buzz lightyears
she she told me this saved and i agree
we had gotten used to a normal that
isn't normal
for people to live but you don't realize
because you're in the game when you get
out of the game
they go hey dude you shot 30 [ __ ]
shots like
i did yeah like yeah man you're not
passing the ball you're like
oh [ __ ] yeah you don't realize until you
stop and you look outside and someone
goes dude you gotta
start passing them your girl said the
same thing 100 saved our marriage
100 percent and and i was moving a
million
miles did you know it was a problem no
me neither no i was moving
because i would see and didn't you think
you were doing things for your family
yeah yeah
i was moving a million miles an hour and
then i was like oh and i go through my
head and i go hey look we made this
i have a rule when i do stand up you
know it's 20 they just wire the money
you have to give me a physical check if
you don't give me a physical check i
don't feel like i accomplished
anything i feel bad about it so they
always give me a physical check because
i take that check
oh that's dope and i come home i go hey
baby here you go
and i thought here you go was checking
the boxes it's
not it's i we i had this and then i put
because i'd feel so much
resentment for being on the road missing
my kids i would go
overtime with them but then i wouldn't
do anything with my wife
man it is so similar they read the same
book
but but it makes you realize also dude
like
they have been do they have endured
and endure is not the right word but
they've put up with our lifestyle
but which isn't here's the difference
you you your wife met you when you were
a comic right yes you've been a standout
for how long josh
uh yeah my girl met me when i was a ufc
fighter and i was renting a one-bedroom
studio in
in playa vista and i had nothing i had
no money
and then she didn't sign up for this so
then it goes from that oh i didn't know
this was gonna happen
and i go from that then i'm now on this
comic i'm touring all the time and i've
podcast three different podcasts i'm
doing this and you know
she's like dude i didn't sign up for
this totally i didn't know either and by
the way she's not wrong
no she's not wrong and what you realize
also is that
not only was because
you were always blinders go go go go i
brought that home with me
so the energy i had at home still even i
think it would have been better if i got
home
and i had a hey i'm home it's me and you
i'm home forget everything else me and
you home
but i couldn't get rid of that hustle i
know even when i
walked in my house it's hard to turn it
off even for me now it's hard for me to
turn off but
i'm getting better because of quarantine
i forced myself to and then also
like i i was like oh i bought you a
g-wagon she's like dude
i would rather walk yeah and then have
this jew and have you be home and
present
than constantly thinking about [ __ ] all
the time and not be present
so now it's like we schedule date nights
because when you have two little
kids it's impossible dude so now we sk
we schedule date night
would you and joey diaz told me from the
very start when i started doing stand-up
goes dude
once a week you need to do a date night
with your girl you need to you take time
for you and her i was like
joey's crazy is he or is joey figured it
out no he figured it out
you because at the end our business
by its nature is
in order to be good at it you have to be
a little bit selfish
because your business is you you're not
you're not your business isn't numbers
you're not in accounting
in order to be good at your business you
have to focus
on you and so your partner
and your spouse doesn't need that type
of [ __ ]
all of the time and so if you're not
focusing any of your energy on them
if it's always you you you you you
you're always looking in the mirror
nightmare you don't want to be with that
person and i agree with you man like
some of the things that were said to me
were hard to hear yeah for sure
we're hard to hear but she you know when
she said to me
i in theory when we're on the phone with
each other
on saturday night i look forward to
seeing you in theory
but when i know you're on your way back
from the airport i dread it
because i know what the rest of sunday
is going to be
and by the way my deal with her is i
take the first flight back
so if i i don't [ __ ] around i don't 6
a.m flight me too
but but that makes me super tired for
sunday me too i'm not present so i'm not
present
i started so now i booked like 10 a.m
flights or 11 so
i'm not waking up at 5 30. but i'm now
i'm like am i missing too much of the
day
right but at least when i come back i'm
a very [ __ ] zombie
or an [ __ ] yeah or yeah his [ __ ]
or sleeping on the couch yeah kids are
like what the [ __ ] dude
i i this is weird like it's been a
blessing with this kovit man
it's so because thanks newsome if she
if she had just woken up one day and
said i can't do this
i would have been like this is coming
out of nowhere because you think you're
awesome
you think you're awesome she would have
been like you're killing it is it coming
out of nowhere
isn't it funny we haven't spoken to each
other in eight months about something
relevant
is this really out of nowhere so like i
am grateful it was a rough i don't know
about you
but the first couple weeks we were like
we're into each other we're into each
other
and then we fell back into two people
who are used to living by themselves
and so it was a tough couple of months
to figure out is this work do we
still like being with each other yep
and then we realized we do we just have
to re-learn how to do it
yeah and most of the relearning is you
me yeah me too
yeah me too but i feel like i'm a better
person
no me too 100 i feel like and and
i ate some medicine from her that i
needed to eat yeah i agree
i like sometimes you need a little bit
of oh this is who i am
oh especially when you're
you're fooling yourself that you are
like i'm this guy man
i'm this guy i'm the perfect this is not
gonna work out and then that mirror goes
up and you're like oh [ __ ]
oh i i know it was it was eye-opening
yep
when i got off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figured out what you look like i'm
like what this wrote a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son